[موسيقى]
بعد اجتماع مصغر لتقييم الوضع الامني
اعلنت الحكومه الاسرائيليه منع من وصفتهم
بالمصلين والسائحين اليهود من دخول الحرم
القدسي الشريف خلال العشر الاواخر من شهر
رمضان قرار خيب ابال غلات المتطرفين وعلى
راسهم الوزير اتمار بن كثير الذي اعتبره
خطا فادحا لم يجلب السلام بل قد يؤدي الى
تصعيد الموقف لكن شراره التصعيد انطلقت
قبل ذلك عندما اطلقت حكومه نتنياهو العنان
للمستوطنين وممارساتهم الاستفزازيه تحت
حمايه الشرطه التي اعتدت على المصلين
والمرابطين
فرق سافر للوضع التاريخي والقانوني
القائمه في المسجد الاقصى وفي انتهاك
لحرمه الشهر وحريه العباده المشاهد
المروعه التي وضعت اسرائيل في موقف محرج
امام حلفائها وسببت ضررا كبيرا لصورته على
المستوى الدولي كما اقرت بذلك اكثر من جهه
اسرائيليه فهل تمضي حكومه نتنياهو تحت ضغط
وزرائها المتطرفين في سياسه الاقتحامات
بالمسجد الاقصى بعد رمضان وما هي احتمالات
ان يؤدي ذلك لحرب شامله حذرت منها
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاسرائيليه اهلا
بكم في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم وتقبل الله صومكم لم يخرج ما
وقع خلال الاسبوع الماضي من اقتحامات
ومواجهات في الحرم القدسي لم يخرج عما
تعود عليه الفلسطينيون الاعتداءات
اسرائيليه خلال شهر رمضان من كل عام وعلى
القيود والضيقات الامنيه التي تشتد عليهم
وتزيد عاما بعد عاما عن هذه الممارسات
الاسرائيليه السعيده الى تهويد الاقصى
وتقسيمه وتواصلي حاله الاستنفار والتاهب
الامني عشيه الجمعه الاخيره من شهر رمضان
المبارك يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه
الحلقه من القدس الدكتور جمال عمرو الباحث
المختص في شؤون القدس والاقصى من القدس
ايضا سامي ابو شحاده رئيس حزب التجمع
الوطني الديمقراطيه والنائب العربي السابق
في الكنيسه الاسرائيلي ومن عمان سميح
المعايطه وزير الاعلام الاردني السابق
فاهلا بهم جميعا
عن وقت اقتحامات المستوطنين للمسجد الاقصى
خلال الايام العشره الاخيره من الشهر
الفضيل لم يبدد المخاوف من تدهور الاوضاع
واحتمالات التصعيد فقد كشفت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه النقابه عن قرار اتخذ داخل
المؤسسه الامنيه والعسكريه يقضي باستدعاء
جنود الاحتياط العاملين في منظومه الدفاع
الجوي ونصب البطاريات في كل المناطق
الاسرائيليه قبل نهايه الاسبوع الجاري
الوقت ذاته دعت حركته حماس الشعب
الفلسطيني الى النفيري والاعتكاف في
الاقصى المبارك للتصدي لخطط الاحتراف
اكثر من اي وقت مضى اضحى التزام العباده
هنا في الحرم القدسي اهم اساليب المقاومه
لم تعد اقتحامات الاسرائيليين للمسجد
الاقصى حالات فرديه لقد تحولت الى اطار
منظم ترعاه سلطات الاحتلال فما الذي تغير
[تصفيق]
هذا وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي لتمر بن
جفير اعتاد اقتحام الاقصى مرارا في الماضي
بصفته الشخصيه ثم بصفته عضوا في الكنيست
لكنه الان وزير في حكومه نتنياهو التي
توصف بالاكثر يمينيه وتطرفا في اسرائيل
انعش ذلك امال المتطرفين الذين اصبحت
اقتحاماتهم شبه يوميه
يحذر الفلسطينيون من ان اليمين المتطرف
الذي بات صانع القرار في اسرائيل يسعى الى
تسريع مساعي تغيير الوضع القائم في الحرم
القدسي بتقسيمه زمانيا ومكانيا ويعني ذلك
انهاء الوصايه الهاشميه التي تمنح الاردن
حق الاشراف واداره المسجد الاقصى
والمقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه في القدس
المحتله
بقوه السلطه والشرطه الاسرائيليتين اضحت
بوابات الاقصى مشرعه امام المتطرفين
اليهود بينما تتعالى في الاوساط
الفلسطينيه الدعوات للاعتكاف والرباط فيه
من اجل التصدي للخطط الاسرائيليه
ويخشى ان ذلك نذير مرحله قد تعصف بالوضع
الامني في المدن الاسرائيليه
تدرك اسرائيل ذلك جيدا فقد كشفت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه ان جيش الاحتلال نشر
مزيدا من منظومات القبه الحديديه واستدعيه
جنود الاحتياط العاملون في منظومه الدفاع
الجوي ونصبت البطاريات في كل المناطق
الاسرائيليه
ما تتوقعه اسرائيل ليس مجرد ردود فعل
محدوده من فصائل المقاومه على اقتحامات
المسجد الاقصى بل حرب شامله ربما تخرج عن
نطاق السيطره
فحسب تقرير لشعبه الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه امان فان فرصه اندلاع حرب
شامله خلال العام القادم قائمه بنسبه
كبيره يرى معد والتقرير ان ايران وحركه
حماس وحزب الله يعتقدون ان الازمه
السياسيه التي تواجهها حكومه نتنياهو
داخليا اضعفت اسرائيل فباتوا مستعدين
للمخاطره بشن عمليات هجوميه اكثر جراه
يقول التقرير الذي نقلت محتواه صحيفه
هاريتس ان قاده الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه
يطلقون على هذا السيناريو اسم العاصفه
الكامله
الله الله اكبر ليس قرار نتنياهو اذا منع
دخول اليهود الى المسجد الاقصى في الايام
العشره الاخيره من شهر رمضان ليس الا جرعه
تخدير لهدنه محدوده قد تقود الى سيناريو
الانفجار بعد عيد الفطر
نرحب من جديد بضيوفنا ونبدا بالدكتور جمال
عامر في القدس اهلا بك لق حماه في العشر
الاواخر ولكن ماذا عما بعد شهر رمضان
حياك الله استاذ محمد والمشاهدين الكرام
والضيوف الكرام بعد شهر رمضان المبارك كما
كان قبل شهر رمضان المبارك قبل شهر رمضان
كنت تحدثت لوسائل الاعلام من ان شيطنه
الاقصى والمسره وشيطنه رمضان في الاعلام
الاسرائيلي بشهر قبل رمضان انما هو تحضير
لجريمه مكتمله الاركان سوف تحصل الجميل في
اتمار بن جبير انه ضحى يعني في العمق
السياسي وانه يعني بسهوله يمكنك ان تقرا
ما يدور في خلجات نفسه تصريحاته والتيك
توك الذي يستخدمه ونقراه جيدا ادركنا
يريد صوره نصر ونصر كبير ويريد في رمضان
الذي شيطنه وشيطا المصلين والمرابطين
والمعتكفين وعباد الرحمن اجمعين شيطنهم
بالجمله انهم انما يريد تفريغ الاقصى
وبمنطق القوه والعنجهيه لاجل ارضاء
الناخبين الاسرائيلي من عتات المستوطنين
فيما فيما يسمى عيد الفصح اليهودي هذه
بالضبط استاذ محمد الذي حصل قبل رمضان هذا
هو نفسه المتوقع بعد رمضان فلذلك ابن كبير
غضب على نتنياهو ولكنه جهز نفسه لما بعد
رمضان وسيعود حليمه لعادتها القديمه سيعود
مجددا بكل قوه وعن جهيه
ويضرب الابعاد الخطيره يعني رؤساء الشباك
السابقين والموساد السابقين ووزراء الحرب
الاسرائيليين السابقين قالوا انت يعني
تسوق اسرائيل الى الهاويه انت يعني تجاوزت
كل الخطوط الحمراء وانت الان تريد ان
تورطنا في اتحاد الساحات الفلسطينيه كلها
ولا واكثر من ذلك اتحاد يعني المناصره من
الشعوب العربيه والاسلاميه في كل اركان
الدنيا ماذا انت فاعل هذا ما نتوقعه استاذ
محمد ان بعد العيد سوف يكون هناك جديد
من جديد سيضربون من جديد ولكل حادثه حديث
نعم اذا استمر الوضع على هذا الشكل وازداد
حده
سيد سميح المعايطه في عمان هل تتوقع ان
تتوتر اكثر العلاقه بين اسرائيل والاردن
الاردن التي تحظى برعايه الاماكن المقدسه
موقع اكسيوس قال بان العلاقه توترت اكثر
من من السابق بين الاردن واسرائيل بسبب
هذه الاقتحامات حتى ان بعض الجهات
الاسرائيليه
مستاءه جدا كما ذكر من وزير الخارجيه ايمن
الصفدي ويعتبرونه متطرفا هذا وفق تعبيرهم
طبعا هل تتوقع ان تزداد الامور حده بين
الاردن واسرائيل بهذا الشان
مساء الخير لحضرتك ولكل المشاهدين مساء
الخير في الحقيقه الامور احنا فتره التردد
بالعلاقات بين الاردن واسرائيل كانت طويله
من 2015 16 17 لل 21 وبعد سقوط حكومه
نتنياهو تحسنت العلاقه مع الحكومه التي
جاءت بعديها ثم مع عوده ب 2022 كان الحذر
وكان الترقب الاردني خليني اقول للاشياء
السيئه القادمه من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ولن تمضي ايام على تشكيل الحكومه حتى كمان
يقتحم الاقصى وجانتنياهو الى عمان واعتذر
واصدر واتحدث عن انه يحترم المعاهده
ويحترم الاتفاقيات القائمه والوصايا
الهاشميه لكن الاردن بعرف انه تجربته
المريره مع حكومات نتنياهو تقول ان الترجي
بالعلاقات السياسيه بين اسرائيل والاردن
يذهب الى الى الاسوا دائما وفي الفتره
الاخيره بالتاكيد يعني العلاقه ذهبت الى
فترات برود
ذهبت الى فترات سيئه جدا لانه اسرائيل بما
تفعل هي تقوم تتطاول على خليني اقول
الوصايه الهاشميه تتطاول على المعاهده
الاردنيه الاسرائيليه تتطاول على ما اتفق
عليه من عدم تغيير الوضع القائم بالقدس
ولما نحكي الوضع القائم بالقدس هذه قضيه
منذ الدوله العثمانيه ليست جديده والوصايا
الهاشميه من عام 24 يعني قبل قيام كيان
الاحتلال بمعنى هنالك ثوابت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تتجاوزها احنا بالاردن بنعرف
جيدا ان نتنياهو ليس اقل تطرفا من من بقيه
التنظيمات من وغيره لكنه اكثر ذكاء واكثر
براجماتيه بالتعامل
يعني خلال فتراته السابقه قبل هذه الحكومه
كانت تتم اقتحامات للاقصى لانه في معتقد
سياسي ومعتقد ديني يهودي بما يتعلق
بالاماكن المقدسه بالقدس وبما يتعلق
بالقدس كلها بالتحويل وفي سعي اسرائيلي
للتقسيم المكاني والزماني للمسجد الاقصى
محل صراع سياسي طويل بين الاردن واسرائيل
وبين العرب والمسلمين بشكل عام مع اسرائيل
فالمتوقع ان تذهب الامور الى مزيد من
التردي بالعلاقات حتى ما قالوا ايمن
الصفدي من تصريحات بعتقد انها تصريحات
موفقه وتناسب التطرف الاسرائيلي وتناسب مع
فعلوه الاسرائيلين بالفترات القادمه
الماضيه وبالتالي نوع ما تفعله اسرائيل هي
محاوله للتذاكر على الناس بالتصعيد ثم
التهدئه ثم التصعيد ثم التهدئه نتيجه
الضغوط التي تجري عليه لكن بالاردن بالذات
احنا تجربتنا واضحه معنا نعرف جيدا نعرف
الالاعيب السياسيه
لنتنياهو بالتاكيد ان الاردن الذي ذهب الى
الحدود القصوى في العلاقات السيئه مع
اسرائيل فيما قبل 2021 مستعد للعوده مره
اخرى الى هذا التردي لانه قضيه الوصايا
الهاشميه احمد ينظر لها الاردن ليست
برستيج سياسي
هي نوع من الواجب والمعركه والصراع مع
الاسرائيليين لانه بديل الاردن بديل
الهاشميين في اداره المسجد الاقصى هي ان
تذهب الى اداره وزاره الاديان الاسرائيليه
وان تكون تحت وصايه الاحتلال وهذا احنا
يعني هذا الامر ندركه جيدا والاردن يقوم
بدوره الى حين قيامه الفلسطينيه
وتشقاء الفلسطينيين معهم نعم ولكن اذا
رجحنا ان الامور ستذهب
في الغالب نحو مزيد من الاقتحامات سيد
سامي ابو شحاده والى مزيد من التدهور في
العلاقه بين الاردن واسرائيل لهذا السبب
هل معنى ذلك ان نتنياهو سيعود مره اخرى
رهينه بالكامل لما يوصف بالتيار الاكثر
تطرفا منه في الحكومه بمعنى انه بعد
انعكسه خلال العشره ايام هذه سيعود الى
مزيد من التناغم معه والارتهان الى
توجهاته
تحياتي لك ولجميع المشاهدين والمشاهدات
اخي محمد رمضان كريم وفي صح مجيد وكل عام
وشعبنا بخير اخي موجود امام ازمه جديه
حقيقيه داخليه وهو يحاول ان يصدر هذه
الازمه الى يعني الى الخارج ولذلك هو يقوم
باستعمال بنك فيرك احد ادواته يعني انا
اولا باعتقادي علينا ان لا نشدد اكثر من
اللازم على لانه بدون بين يمين نتنياهو ما
كانوا هؤلاء وزراء وليس فقط نتنياهو هناك
اغلبيه في الكنيسه الاسرائيلي رات
بالارهابيات بالارهابيين بحسب القانون
الاسرائيلي
وجهت لهم بالسابقتهم بالارهاب بحسب
القانون الاسرائيلي ولكن شركائهم في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه من حزب شاص وحزب
المتدينين اليهود
وحزب الليكود الحزب الاكبر في اسرائيل
رغبهم لاعبين شرعيين اي ان المشكله
هي اكبر بكثير من بنك فيروس مودريتش
المشكله ان هناك مجتمع ودوله تدهورت بشكل
كبير جدا
باتجاه اليمين واليمين الفاشي ما يقومون
به هذه هي رؤيتهم وهم لا يخفوها اخي محمد
من يقرا البرنامج السياسي
لاحزاب بنك فير وسم معنيون بالحرب مكتوب
في برنامجهم السياسي عنهم معنيون بالحرب
الشامله من اجل الحسم ومن اجل تغيير كل
يعني ما جرى من نتائج الحرب في الحروبات
في دوله اسرائيل وهم يريدون المزيد من
الحرب يريدون انهاء الملف الفلسطيني وما
يزيد ازمه نتنياهو انهم ايضا يريدون ان
يحسموا على الساحه الاسرائيليه داخليا
بينهم وبين المتظاهرين الذين رايناهم في
الاربعه اشهر الاخيره يعني هم يريدون ان
ينهوا ملف
الوهم السابق الذي كان يسمى بدوله يهوديه
وديمقراطيه بالحسم بشكل واضح نحو اليهوديه
فقط وحتى الهامش الديمقراطي الصغير جدا
اخي محمد يريدون ان يمحوه تماما
دكتور جمال عمرو الكل يتحدث عن ان اسرائيل
ماضيه بشكل مدروس وتصاعدي فيما يسمى بفرض
التقسيم الزماني والمكاني للمسجد الاقصى
اريد ان اسمع منك
تعليق حول هذا التوجه ولكن بعد ان نتابع
هذا التقرير الذي يحاول ان يشرح ما معنى
التقسيم الزماني والمكان للقدس للمسجد
الاقصى عفوا
شكل عام 2003 نقطه تحول في اقتحامات
المستوطنين اليهودي للمسجد الاقصى المبارك
حيث سمحت شرطه الاحتلال انذاك للمستوطنين
باقتحامه تحت حمايتها كامر واقع
التقسيم الزماني الذي تحاول اسرائيل فرضه
يعني تخصيص اوقات محدده لدخول المسلمين
واخرى خاصه باليهود باكتساب الساعات
والايام طوال العام
وبموجبه بات على المسلمين افراغ المسجد
الاقصى لساعات محدده يوميا ليصلي اليهود
ثلاث صلوات في الاقصى
كما تسعى اسرائيل الى تخصيص المسجد الاقصى
لليهود خلال اعيادهم التي تصل الى 100 يوم
وجميع ايام السبت اما التقسيم المكاني فهو
تخصيص مناطق وزوايا معينه من المسجد
الاقصى لكل من الطرفين حيث تسعى الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لاقتطاع منطقتين
وينظر الى محاولات اسرائيل فرض التقسيم
الزمني والمكاني كخرق للوضع التاريخي
والقانوني القائم الذي ساد منذ فتره
الدوله العثمانيه مرورا بالانتداب
البريطاني والحكم الاردني وصولا الى بدايه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عام
الذي بموجبه تقتصر الصلاه في المسجد على
المسلمين وحدهم ولفرد مخططاتها تعتمد
اسرائيل على قانون القوه فتعمد الى ابعاد
المصلين عن الاقصى لاشهر وتمنع منهم دون
الاربعين من الصلاه فيه كما تحضر ما تسميه
تنظيم المرابطين والمرابطات وتعتدي على
المعتكفين وتاخذ الاقتحامات مسارا اساسيا
داخل الاقصى يبدا المستوطنون من باب
المغاربه ويسيرون حتى باب السلسله مسافه
تمتد 100 متر تقريبا ويتجولون في ساحات
المسجد الاقصى بالقرب من الصور الغربي
وتوسعت الاقتحامات مؤخرا حتى بات
المستوطنون يجيبون الاقصى بكامله تقريبا
دكتور جمال عمرو هل ستمضي اسرائيل قدما في
هذا الاتجاه بلا تردد
نعم طالما ان هذه الحكومه بهذه البنيه
السياسيه التي اشار اليها
لسميرون وسيمضون ولم يردعهم رادع لانهم
يستمدون هذا الفكر المتطرف من ايام جابوا
تنسكي يوم من ايام ايضا كهانه ومن ايام
باروكه صاحب المذبح الشهيره في رمضان في
المسجد الابراهيمي في الخليل هم يقولون
بالقوه سنفرض سياساتنا وسنثبت وجودنا في
اقدس مقدساتنا ولذلك جهزوا معهد الهيكل
وانيت الهيكل وازياء الهيكل
وبنوا في ذهنهم هيكل معنوي وهذه المنظمات
اللي بالامس القريب كانت دوله الاحتلال
تختبئ وراءها انها منظمات يمنيه تريد
الصلاه ومؤمنين يهود يريدون الصلاه في جبل
الهيكل اليوم لم تعد كذلك اليوم هي نفس
شكلت الحكومه هي انتخبت الحكومه وانصهرت
فيها واصبحت الان مدعومه بالجيش والشرطه
والاستخبارات يعني اختلفت الصوره تماما
ولهالسبب يشعرونهم بالقوه ويشعرون ان
ورائهم حكومه قويه ويريدون الاستمرار ولكن
هم عيونهم الوقت طالما استاذ محمد انتم
اشرتم انه في التقرير انهم نشروا القبه
الحديديه في كل مكان هم عيونهم في ذات
الوقت ما الذي يجري من تحولات في المنطقه
ومصالحات استراتيجيه تاريخيه ما الذي يجري
بين السعوديه وايران ما الذي يجري من
مصالحه في اليمن سوريا لبنان الاردن
الشقيق ما الذي يجري في مصر مع سوريا كل
هذه يحسبون لها حساب على مدار الساعه صار
منشغل بالهم لكنهم في ذات الوقت مش
متخليين ابدا عن الاقصى رغم اننا ناشدنا
مرات عديده ان يكون فيهم رجل رشيد وان
يتركوا الاقصى لاهل الاقصى لا بدلا من ذلك
يا سيدي قدموا اول قربان الطبيب الفلسطيني
شهيد محمد العصي في باب السلسله في اول
رمضان تخيل
وبالتالي قالوا الكاميرات الثمانيه ما
صورت الجريمه كما ان كاميرات ثم صورتش
جريمه اعدام شيرين ابو عاقلي ولليوم ما
معترفين ويا ريت وقفت عند الاقصى والشهداء
الفلسطينيين لا راحوا كمان الان راحوا على
بقيه الشعب الفلسطيني وقالوا لا سبت نور
ولا تسهيلات للمسيحيين ونطوق كنيسه
القيامه وبعدين مع هاي الحكومه وبعدين
يعني ماذا تريدون اذا يعني هم مستمرون في
تحدي الاردن ويعني يقولون عن الحقيقه بانه
يتمار بن جفير الاردن يعني بداوا يشيطلوه
كما شيطنوا رمضان وشيطنوا المصلين شيطان
والمرابطين واعتبروا الرباط قال الرباط
ايش الرباط تنظيم ومحظور طب ما هو الرباط
استاذ محمد هو جزء من العقيده كما هو
الاعتكاف جزء من العقيده الاسلاميه لماذا
محظور يا نعم هذا هو السؤال اذا ظلت
الامور في هذا التص عيد سيد سميح المعايطه
هل معنى ذلك بان الوصايه الهاشميه على
الاماكن المقدسه
ليس ستصبح في خطر وانما قد تدمر بالكامل
او حتى تلغى
يعني شوف زي ما حكيت لحضرتك قبل انه احنا
بنعتبر الوصايا هي جزء من الصراع مع
المحتل على حمايه الاماكن المقدسه بالقدس
يعني وهذا امر ندرك وندرك ان الاسرائيليين
لديهم مشاريعهم في تهويد القدس في تهويد
المكان والانسان والحجر وكل شيء هم لديهم
هذا المشروع والاردن يقوم بجهد مضاد في في
الحفاظ على هويه القدس الحفاظ على هويه
المقدسات والاردن يدرك ويتحدث ان المسجد
الاقصى والاماكن المقدسه ليست هي المسجد
فقط هي 44 دونم مساحه كبيره هي الاماكن
المقدسه التي مشموله بالوصايه هنالك اوقاف
هنالك مدارس هنالك تعليم للقران الكريم
هنالك موظفين بتشرف عليهم هيئه الاوقاف
التابعه للاوقاف في الاردن بمعنى احنا
بنعرف انها معركه مع الاسرائيليين طويله
الامد وان الاسرائيليين لديهم مشروع يعني
ديني ومشروع سياسي ولديهم تطرف في هذا
الموضوع لكن احنا بنادي واجبنا ببذ كل ما
نستطيع في هذا الموضوع يعني الوصايه
الهاشميه ليس في هدف بمعنى انه مش القصه
ان يكون هنالك دور
الهاشميين في حمايه المقدسات هذا واجب
وهذه رساله وهذا جزء من الصراع اللي
بالخضره للاخر والاردن يستعمل علاقاته
السياسيه مع الامريكان مع العرب مع
الاوروبيين يستعمل معاهده السلام لمقاومه
هذا المشروع الاسرائيلي لكن بنهايه المطاف
تعرف قصه القدس هي قصه فلسطينيه عربيه
اسلاميه بمعنى ان الاردن وحده يجب ان يسند
ويجب ان يكون واذا كان في اي خطوه الى بين
قوسين انتصار لا سمح الله اسرائيلي في هذا
الموضوع هو بنتحمله جميعا كعربه ومسلمين
بشكل اساسي فالاردن بيقوم دوره بنعرف انه
هذا يعني كيان محتل لديه لديه فكر صهيوني
لديه فكره المودي لديه مشاريع يقوم عليها
بتعرف حضرتك من ال67 بعد احتلال القدس عام
بدات الحفريات تحت المسجد الاقصى يعني
بنحكي عن اكثر من 57 عام وبنحكي عن قصه
الهيكل المزعوم وبنحكي عن قصص كثيره
بذلوها في تفريغ القدس من اهلها في شراء
الدول الاماكن في تقويم سيد الغريب سيد
معايطه ان انتفاق واد عربه عام 94 نص على
هذه الوصايه الهاشميه ايضا اتفاق في 2015
وبرعايه امريكيه حول المسجد الاقصى ومع
ذلك اسرائيل لا تحترم ذلك هناك نقطه ايضا
نسال عنها السيد سامي ابو شحاده
اسرائيل تدرك تماما بان ما قامت به في
المسجد الاقصى لطخ بين قوسين سمعتها
الدوليه بشكل كبير حتى ان موقع الكتروني
للقناه السابعه الاسرائيليه وهو محسوبه
على المستوطنين يقول اصبح الان لدى العالم
نحن الاشرار والفلسطينيون هم هم الاخيار
وبان سمعتنا اصبحت سيئه جدا في العالم هل
تعتقد بان هذا الاعتبار يمكن ان يكون له
اي حساب لدى الحكومه الاسرائيليه وهي تنظر
الى ما يجري الان
اخي محمد اولا قررنا نتنياهو بمنع اليهود
من الدخول الى المسجد الاقصى في العشر
الاواخر من شهر رمضان يعني ما كنا نؤكد
عليه بشكل دائم ان حكومات اسرائيل
واعيه لقدسيه هذا المكان للمسلمين
ووعي الى حساسيه اللعب بهذا الملف وهي
تاخذ هذه القرارات بشكل واعي من اجل اشعال
المنطقه اي ان الامور لا تحدث بالغلط او
بالصدفه الامور تحدث بشكل واعي بدون ان
نعي ذلك لا يمكن فهم هذا القرار وانا
باعتقادي هناك ايضا نوع من الوقاحه
الاسرائيليه المعهوده في هذا القرار اي ان
اسرائيل تعلم انها تقوم بجريمه وان هذه
عمليه استفزازيه وانه لا يحق لها وان
الاقصى هو للمسلمين وللمسلمين فقط ولكنها
اجلت جريمتها عده ايام للاستمرار بها بعد
شهر رمضان لمصالح سياسيه
ضيقه من المهم ايضا اخي محمد ان نذكر ان
هناك تضييق كبير جدا على اهلنا المسيحيين
في هذا الاسبوع المقدس في اسبوع الفصح
وفي اسبوع الالام هناك صديقات كبيره جدا
ومنع وصول المصلين في صفط النور القريب
لقد كانت هذه القرارات قبل ما يقارب اليوم
ان هناك تضييقات على المسلمين وعلى
المسيحيين ولا توجد حريات اديان في هذا
الكيان الا لليهود فقط في اماكنهم المقدسه
وايضا في الاماكن التي لا تتبع لهم مثل
المسجد الاقصى نتنياهو يستعمل ورقه المسجد
الاقصى من اجل ان يصدر ازمته الداخليه الى
الخارج وانا باعتقادي في الوضع الذي موجود
به نتنياهو اصبح اكثر خطرا لان ما يقود
نتنياهو في هذه المرحله هو الجنائيه في
المحاكم الاسرائيليه
نتنياهو يحتاج هذا الائتلاف بدون هذا
الائتلاف قد يجد نفسه بالسجن ولذلك هو
مستعد ان يقدم كل التنازلات لبنك مع كل
تطرفهم وجنودهم وعنصريتهم وعن جهيتهم يعني
اعتباراته اعتبارات شخصيه ويريد ان ينجو
من المحاكمه ولذلك هو يعني من علينا ان
نتوقع اي سيناريو اخي محمد من هذه الحكومه
نتنياهو ايضا يعاني الان من تدني كبير في
مستوى الشعبيه نتيجه الاوضاع الامنيه
والكثير وكذلك نتيجه ما يسمى بالانقلاب
القضائي وموجه الاحتجاجات الكبيره في
اسرائيل
اشار استطلاع للراي نشره الموقع الاخباري
الاسرائيلي ولا الى ان 71% من
الاسرائيليين غير راضيين عن اداء حكومه
نتنياهو بينما دلت نتائج استطلاع اخر نشرت
القناه الثالثه عشره الاسرائيليه ان واحدا
وخمسين في المئه من الاسرائيليين يفضلون
زعيم حزب المعسكر الرسمي
لرئاسه الوزراء وان 42% يفضلون زعيم حزب
هناك مستقبل يا ايرلابيب بينما لم يتجاوز
نصيب نتنياهو 34% واشار الاستطلاع ذاته
الى انه لو جرت الانتخابات في اسرائيل
اليوم فان حزب الليكود بزعامه نتنياهو
سينهار وستتراجع حصته في الكنيست من 32
مقعدا الى عشرين وان مجموعه ما سيحصل عليه
تحالف احزاب اليمين المتطرف والمتدينين
الاصوليين برئاسته لن يتجاوز 46 مقعدا في
حين سيضاعف حزب جانس نصيبه وسيحصد 29
مقعدا
وسيحصل مع احزاب يمين الوسط والوسط
واليسار على 64 مقعدا اما نصيب الاحزاب
العربيه فسيصل الى عشره مقاعد
هذا هذا التراجع في شعبيه نتنياهو الدكتور
جمال عمر هل يمكن ان يدفعه الى خوض مغامره
حرب مع غزه مع لبنان مع غيرها من الجبهات
خاصه وانه هدد في مؤتمره الصحفي الاخير في
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه كما تسمى هدد
الجبهات عديده هدد غزه لبنان سوريا وايران
كذلك طبعا
وهذا الخطاب الذي
للمتطرف لكنه بات اليوم حمامه سلام وهو
وغيره قالوا عن هذا الخطاب بانه اخرق وانه
خطاب يعني تافه سياسيا اكرمكم الله
واتحدثوا بانها نتنياهو في ثنايا خطابه
كان مهزوما وتحدث عن ان قوه الردع
الاسرائيليه تتلاشى ولذلك هو يريد التهديد
لغرض لرفع المنسوب فاذا به يخسر
صديقه دونيل ترامب تماما هدد فخسر على كل
الاحوال ازمه نتنياهو عميقه جدا ولديه
مجتمع من ورائه منقسم تماما ونحن نشاهد
المظاهرات ونشاهد الانقسام الراسي والافقي
ايضا نشاهد ان نتنياهو يتباد الادوار مع
اصدقائه
لغرض تماسك الحكومه اطول وقت ممكن لعله
يخرج من الازمه ولعله الاقليم كله يهدا
لانه الاقليم على مرجل ساخن يغلي تماما
ليس في فلسطين فحسب انما في المحيط في
الاقليم نفسه الاردن غاضبه سوريا غاضبه
لبنان من العراق الامه العربيه كلها غاضبه
حتى المطبعين العرب باتوا خجلانين
ومستحيين على حالهم كمان اذا اقول لك يا
اخي ان موضوع نتنياهو سقط في يعني في مكره
وخداعه واليوم مشكله نتنياهو اعمق من ان
يحلها من خلال هذه التهديدات
نتنياهو قام بجريمه لا يجوز فيها ان يعاتب
ايمن الصفدي بالاردن ولا يجوز ان يعاتب اي
فلسطيني الان يصلي في الاقصى عندما يعلن
نتنياهو بعظمه لسانه استاذ محمد بانه الان
مسموح يبدا المستوطنون في اقتحامه الاقصى
وال ان وقفوا اقتحام الاقصى يعني انت
بتلعب حاكمه وجلاد يعني من خولك يا
نتنياهو يعني تلعب بالنار في اقدس مقدسات
المسلمين والتي هي ليست الفلسطينيين هذا
الاقصى امه الاسلام في كل الكون وهذه
كنيسه القيامه لكل المسيحيين الاحرار في
كل الكون من خولك نتنياهو ان تلعب بالنار
من سمح لك ذلك وبالتالي اظن ان نتنياهو
يخطئ خطيئه العمر الان وسيلحق وراء دونالد
ترامب الى المحكمه شاء وعليه ان يتذكر
جيدا هزيمه باب الاسباط وبواباته
الالكترونيه التي رمى بها الى مذهب
للتاريخ
لو نتوقف قليلا الان فيما تبقى من
البرنامج مع التقرير شعبه الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه امان تحدثت عن فرصه
او فرص مرتفعه لاندلاء حرب شامله خلال
العام المقبل قالت بان ذلك قد لا يكون
بالضروره نتيجه التخطيط وانما ربما اخطاء
من هنا او هناك تؤدي الى اندلاع الجبهات
وتحدثت ايضا وهنا نسال سيد سميح المعايطه
تحدث التقرير ايضا عن
اهتزاز
مكانه اسرائيل في المنطقه
وقوه الردعه التي لديها وهذا يعود ايضا
حتى حسب التقرير دائما الى اهتمام امريكي
بمناطق اخرى غير الشرق الاوسط يعني هناك
ازمه ازمه استراتيجيه تعانيها اسرائيل هل
هل تعتقد بان الامور فعلا قد تسير في هذا
الاتجاه
شوف حضرتك على ضوء المعطيات بعتقد انه
احنا ممكن نتوقع ازمات نتوقع مراحل تصعيد
صحيح لكن حرب شامله بعتقد انه ظروف الدول
وظروف الاقليم والظرف العربي والظرف
الفلسطيني والظرف الاسرائيلي ايضا لا يذهب
باتجاه يعني خوض حروب شامله في العلاقه
بتحدثوا بتقدير استخبارات الاسرائيليه عن
العام القادم هسا المنطقه اذا بدك تروح
على اشياء تاتي طفره نتيجه خطا من دوله
تدخل في مواجهه غير محسوبه ثم تذهب الامور
باتجاهات ابعد ممكن لكن بمسار مخطط له
مسار يعني ضمن المعطيات بعتقد انه احنا
ممكن نتنبا بفترات تصعيد ممكن نتنبا
بفترات اكثر يعني صعوبه اليوم المنطقه
بجوز ازماتها تذهب الى الحلول يعني بعض
التغيرات في معادلات الاقليم اليوم
بالعلاقات بين دول الاقليم الموجود
العربيه وايران وتركيا وغيرها تذهب الى
تفكيك ازمات ولا تذهب تعقيد والى بناء
ازمات جديده وهذا الامر بيكون يعني مخالف
بتقدير للمنطقه اللي بتحدثوا فيه
الاسرائيليين لكن هل هناك مخاوف اسرائيليه
ربما الاسرائيليين ربما بنوا يعني لديهم
معلومات او لديهم توقعات بانه اسرائيل
ضربه الى ايران اذا حدث مثل هذا الامر
بالتاكيد هذه قضيه مختلفه عن المسار
الطبيعي لمسار المنطقه لكن اذا حيدنا هذه
المعطيات غير الموجوده الان وغير المحسوبه
في هذه الفتره بعتقد المنطقه تذهب الى
تفكيك الازمات الى تبريد العلاقات اللي
كانت ساخنه بين دول الاقليم وتذهب الى
خليني اقول يعني محاوله لصناعه اكثر ود
اكثر في العلاقات في داخل الاقليم بين
العرب وغير العرب بالاقليم لكن بالتاكيد
انه اسرائيل بالشكل الذي عليه احنا بنتحدث
اليوم عن اولويات
ان يحافظ على الائتلاف الذي يقوده وان
يحافظ على كما يقال على يمسك العصا من
الوسط مع الاحزاب المتطرفه معه بالحكومه
حتى لا يتفكك هذا الائتلاف وان يذهب الى
موضوع اصلاح القضاء لانه في القصه تتعلق
بامن الشخصي وبمستقبل الشخصي ومستقبل
السياسي هذه اولويها بالمراحل القادمه
وليس مسارات اخرى كما قلت اذا موضوع ضربه
لايران مفاجاه ثم تتوالى
التفجرات بالمنطقه هذا مسار مختلف غير غير
ذلك المنطقه تذهب الى تبريد الازمات وليس
الى تصعيد الازمات هذا السيناريو سيد سامي
ابو شحاده سمته الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه كما نقلت هاردس بسيناريو
العاصفه الكامله قد لا تكون كامله بمعنى
البعض قد يقول بانها قد تذهب اسرائيل في
حرب مع غزه مثلا ليس بالضروره مع لبنان
لانها تريد تجنب مواجهه مع حزب الله
الضربات مع سوريا مستمره من فتره الى اخرى
وليس بالضروره حرب شامله ماذا ترجح
اولا عزيزي يعني بدنا نكون حذرين جدا هون
باستعمال المصطلحات لا لا يمكن ان تكون مع
اسرائيل حرب شامله لا يوجد قوه عسكريه
للفلسطينيين او للبنان
لتكون يعني قوه موازيه لاسرائيل من اجل
الدخول الى حرب شامله ما يمكن ان يكون هو
عدوان اسرائيلي
والجميع مدرك بالرغم من الازمات الداخليه
وبالرغم من كل ما تمر به الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ان اسرائيل خلقت اداه حرب وحش
كبير جدا لديه قدره تدميريه كبيره جدا
والجميع ياخذ ذلك بعين الاعتبار الجميع
ياخذ ذلك بعاني الاعتبار يعني لا يوجد لا
لدى حماس ولا لدى الجهاد الاسلامي ولا حتى
لدى لبنان سلاح طيران موازي لسلاح الطيران
الاسرائيلي او قوه تدميريه موازيه ولذلك
من الممكن ان يكون هناك عدوان اسرائيلي
هنا او هناك كما كان يتخيل نحن موجودين في
في مكان كل عده سنوات هناك حرب يعني
اسرائيل
كانت بالعدوان على لبنان عام 2006
2008 عدوان على غزه وبال 2014 عدوان على
غزوه 21 يعني بشكل دائم هناك عدوان لان
الاحتلال
محمد بتعريفه هو عمليه ارهابيه مستمره
يوميا
والمحتل يعلم انه غير شرعي وغير مقبول
ولذلك يحاول ان يفرض نفسه بالقوه بشكل
دائم ويخلق حاله الردع الا ان الشعب
العربي الفلسطيني هذا الشعب البطل الذي
نفتخر به
لا يعني لن يردعه هذا الاحتلال وهو يقاوم
على مدار قرن من الزمان وهو متمسك بقضيته
ومتمسك بثوابته الوطنيه ولديه استعداد
كبير جدا
للنضال للتضحيه ولديها ايضا مشروع هو
مشروع افضل
انسانيا وديمقراطيه واكثر عداله من هذا
المشروع الصهيوني الاستعماري
نقوم في نهايه هذه الجوله في نهايه هذه
الحلقه بجوله بين ضيوفنا لنستطلع
ماذا يرى كل واحد منهم بخصوص الفتره
المقبله سواء في العلاقه بالمسجد الاقصى
او في امكانيه اندلاع حرب في الفتره
المقبله نبدا بالدكتور جمال عمرو ثم سميح
المعايطه وننهي بالسيد
سامي ابو شحاته تفضل سيد دكتور عمرو
استاذ محمد لست اطلاقا مقتنع بان الاعلام
الاسرائيلي يمكن تصديقه ولا استخدام الفاظ
ولا عاصفه شامله ولا حرب شامله ولا كامله
انما هو اعلام يريد ان ينبه المجتمع
الاسرائيلي الى خطر دائم قادم من الساحات
كلها وان عليهم ان يتوحدوا ويتوقفوا عن
مهزله الانقسام وان يطيل عمري الحكومه ما
استطاعوا اليه سبيلا لكن انا دعني لمده
نصف دقيقه اكون محامي للشيطان واقول
لنتنياهو يمكنك اطاله ليس بالاعلام وليس
بهذه الطريقه وليس بالتهويل والتهويل ضد
رمضان وضد الاقصى وضد الاردن وضد لا لا
دعني انصحك يا نتنياهو بان تتجه باتجاهين
اثنين قد تطيل عمر حكومتك وهي العمل سرا
وعلنا وبسرعه فائقه لاسترجاع جنودك من غزه
وهم احياء ير هكذا هكذا نحن نتخيل ثانيا
ان تهتم
باصدقائك في الائتلاف وتوقف هؤلاء الزعران
عند حدهم وتعطي الحريه الكامله للاردن في
اداره الاوقاف الاسلاميه في الاقصى
والهيئه الاسلاميه العليا حذرت من ذلك
طويلا من هذه تجاوزات وانت ايضا تترك
الحريه الكامله لمسيحيين في مقدساتهم
وتتوقف عن مصادره ممتلكاتهم هذه تستطيع
بها ان تستمر اكثر واكثر وبالتالي انا
اتوقع بالتاكيد وهذا ختان كلامي بالتاكيد
ان نتنياهو لن يقبل بهذه النصيحه وسيواصل
الزعران هؤلاء اكرمكم الله التحدي وستدخل
المنطقه في دوامه من العنف اقل من حرب لكن
اكثر من انتفاضه هذا الذي اتوقعه تماما
بالضبط لماذا لان هنالك يعني اجندات لدى
تنظيمات المقاومه تريد تريد هي ايضا ان
تقول للاسرائيليين نعم قوه الردع لديكم في
ادنى مستوياتها بدناش ندخل معكم في حرب بس
بدنا نذركم بدنا نزلكم بطريقتنا الخاصه
يبدو ان الامور بهذا الاتجاه ذاهبه والله
اعلم نعم سميح المعايطه
سيدي انا يعني توقعاتي ان يذهب نتنياهو
الى تمرير المرحله الى حين اذا استطاع
تمرير موضوع اصلاح القضاء بما يخصه الحفاظ
على الائتلاف الذي يقوده هذا اولا اثنين
لاستمرار في ضربات الموجهه الى تزايد
النفوذ الايراني على العسكري على الارض
السوريه ثم بعد ذلك عندما ينهي من الموضوع
الداخلي
سيعود الى برنامج السياسي الذي كان يتحدث
عنه وهو توسيع علاقاته في الاطار الاسلامي
العربي ومع فك الارتباط بين هذه العلاقات
والقضيه الفلسطينيه بتقديري على قلب
الفترات القادمه هذا الذي يمكن ان يرى من
مسارات للحكومه الاسرائيليه الموجوده
وهل تعتقد ان للاردن مازال له قدره على
التاثير في هذا في هذا المجرى
الاردن سيبذل كل ما يستطيع في هذا الموضوع
وسيقوم بدوره الى الحد الاقصى بجهده وبجهه
بكل علاقاته لانه الخير الاخر ان يدير
ظهره الاردن ويترك هذا الواجب ويترك
الاقصى تحت اداره الاحتلال وهذا لن يقوم
في الاردن في يوم من الايام وبالتالي
الاردن يدرك المعادله يدرك طبيعه الاحتلال
يدرك عدوانيته ويدرك المعادله الدوليه
والاقليميه لكن الاردن يذهب الى الحد
الاقصى في اداء واجبه فيما تحت مظله
الوصايه الهاشميه في الحفاظ على هويه
المقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه بالقدس لن
يتوقف سيبقى يخوضها بالصراع مع المحتل الى
الحد الى يعني الى ما لا نهايه لانه
الخيار الاخر ان يضيف ضهره ويترك الاقصى
للاسرائيليين وهذا ما لا يفعل الاردن ولن
يفعله بالتضافر ايضا مع شرقان او مع الشعب
الفلسطيني الموجود مع كل جهد عربي واسلامي
سامي ابو شحاده
انا التقدير يا اخي محمد انا عائدون خلال
عده ايام الى تعميق الازمه الداخليه في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي سيعودون المتظاهرون
الى الشوارع باعداد اكبر بكثير هذه الازمه
ستتفاقم بشكل كبير جدا
وقد ينجم عنها عده سيناريوهات مختلفه
باعتقادي لان الضغط على وحكومه سيزداد
ايضا من الداخل انا باعتقادي لدينا فرصه
تاريخيه اخي محمد يعني هناك بالفعل حكومه
يمينيه فاشيه لا يستطيع نتنياهو تسويقها
الى العالم انا باعتقادي علينا كفلسطينيين
وكعرب استغلال هذه الفرصه التاريخيه
والعمل بشكل اقوى بكثير على الساحه
الدوليه وزياده الضغط على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لردعها لانه يعني تكرر السؤال
هنا عده مرات لماذا يقوم نتنياهو لا يربط
هذا الثور الاهوج المسمى
ويسمح كل هذا التطرف هذا زي المثل اللي
بيقولوه المصريين لمصاروا فرعون مين فرعنك
قال ما لقيتش مين يردني
فنتنياهو ما لقاش مين يردوا لو كانت هناك
رده فعل اكثر حده من العالم العربي ومن
القياده الفلسطينيه وحصار هذه الحكومه على
المستوى الدولي بشكل اكبر بكثير لكان اذا
كان الوضع افضل بكثير على يعني كافه
المستويات اذا نحن ذاهبون الى تعميق
الازمه الداخليه في اسرائيل خلال عده ايام
سنرى ذلك في الشارع وهذا الضغط على
نتنياهو من الداخل يفتح جميع السيناريوهات
شكرا جزيلا لك السيد سامي ابو شحاده رئيس
حزب التجمع الوطني الديمقراطي والنائب
العربي السابق في الكنيست الاسرائيلي شكرا
ايضا لضيفنا من القدس دكتور جمال عمرو
الباحث المختص في شؤون القدس والاقصى شكرا
ايضا لضيفنا من عمان السيد سميح المعايطه
وزير الاعلام الاردني السابق
الان ننتقل كالعاده الى تغريدات لكتاب
صحفيين حول موضوع هذه الحلقه نبدا مع
الدكتور صالح النعامي الباحث في الشان
الاسرائيلي الذي يقول قراره نتنياهو منعى
اليهود من اقتحام الاقصى خلال العشر
الاواخر من رمضان انتصار للاقصى وحماته من
المعتكفين البواسل والمقاومه صحيح الحكومه
السابقه ايضا منعت اليهود من اقتحامه في
هذه الايام لكننا نتنياهو فعل ذلك هذه
المره رغم معارضه شركائه في اليمين الديني
نتنياهو ادرك ان تدنيس اليهود للاقصى خلال
هذه الايام يمكن ان يفضي الى انفجار يسمح
بظهور مزيد من الدلائل على تهاوي قوه الرد
على الاسرائيليه في الوقت ذاته ادرك
اليمين الديني ممثل ببن كثير حدود القوه
التي يحوزوها وان الواقع اكثر تعقيدا من
استلامهما للرؤى الدينيه والايديولوجيه
المجنونه
والهادئه كما يقول
الدكتور عبد الله معروف مسؤول الاعلام
والعلاقات العامه السابق بالمسجد الاقصى
قال في تغريده لا ننخدع بقرار نتنياهو منع
الاقتحامات في العشر الاواخر من رمضان هذا
القرار كان متخذا منذ البدايه وهم يحاولون
اهامنا الان انه انجاز وذلك للتغطيه على
الانجاز الفعلي وهو مضي الاعتكاف في
المسجد الاقصى قبل العشر الاواخر من رمضان
رغم انف الاحتلال
مركز العوده الفلسطيني قال في الوقت الذي
يمكن فيه لالاف المسيحيين حول العالم
زياره القدس سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تلغي تصاريح الزياره التي كانت اصدرتها
لمئات من الفلسطينيين المسيحيين من قطاع
غزه خلال عيد الفصح ونختم بهذه التغريده
الى الصحفي الاسرائيلي يوني بن مناحيم
يقول فيها تستعد المؤسسه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه ليوم القدس العالمي قد يحاول
محور الشر الذي تقوده ايران مفاجاه
اسرائيل تاهب لوحدات الدفاع الجوي خوفا من
اطلاق الصواريخ واطلاق الطائرات المسيره
باتجاه اسرائيل
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه التي حاولنا فيها ان
نستقرى اتجاهات السياسه الاسرائيليه فيما
يتعلق بالمسجد الاقصى وكذلك ما يمكن ان
يحدث في الفتره المقبله بالنظر الى تقرير
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاسرائيليه حول
اتجاه المنطقه الى مسمته حربا شامله دمتم
في رعايه الله والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]